this is a production of Cornell
University
please welcome
Dr Larry Chase thank you Larry
thank you good morning to everybody and
it's good to have a chance to visit with
you a little bit to
related groundwork for how methane's
produced and some things we can do about
it next slide
next
I'm going to give the summary first
now the summary is optimal room and
function is the key to environmentally
sustainable cows and so really the rest
of the talk we're going to back up and
verify why that is true next slide
so what are the objectives when we put
together a ration for dairy cows well we
obviously want to maximize intake milk
production keep the cows healthy have
the cows breed back
um have the dairyman make a profit
enough nutrients for growth of either
the cow or heifers and we always also
want to put in here we want to minimize
the excretion of nutrients back into the
environment
next slide
let's think what a cow has to do every
day to make 100 pounds of milk and
that's about 12 gallons basically
she has to drink 35 to 45 gallons of
water
and she's going to consume 125 145
pounds of wet feed
that's the input to the factory the
output is that hundred pounds of milk
plus about 160 190 pounds of manure
next slide
what does a cow have to do within the
body to make this these 12 gallons of
milk
she has to form find seven to eight
pounds of glucose which is sugar
she has to make three to four pounds of
microbial protein
needs to make two to two and a half
pounds of amino acids these are the
precursors that she needs to make milk
milk protein and milk fat
all of these are produced by the cow
from the nutrients contained in the feed
so you can see that this cow is really
working very hard to provide these
nutrients to support milk production
next slide
next there we go so let's think now how
do we convert these these various feeds
into milk because these are feeds like
cotton seed and hay and and the corn
silage how does the cow take these and
make them into milk next slide
well if we look at the slide from Greg
Penner at the University of Saskatchewan
at the top the cow consumes a feed then
is moves to the right microbes digest it
microbes grow the microbes produce
energy and protein
the cow regulates the environment for
the microbes to grow so that's sort of
the basic scheme for how the rumen
functions next slide
if we then take a look at what's
different about the digestive system of
the cow versus humans and monogastrics
it's the rumen the number one and number
two the reticulum those two sections of
the count are not present in monogastric
in humans and the rumen is really that
big fermentation vat which could end up
in a large cow to be 40 to 50 gallons of
liquid next slide
so what's the environment like within
the room and that these microorganisms
live well first it's anaerobic no oxygen
a constant temperature about 39 degrees
you can see pH is sort of 666.
saliva buffers
it's fairly wet only 10 15 dry matter
and it's continually mixing and turning
around with chewing rumination
regurgitation of that system next slide
Dr Paul Weimer at the U.S dairy forage
Center put this little chart together to
show what types of microorganisms are in
the rumen and the first group is
bacteria
they make up almost 98 of the no of the
total numbers
about 60 of the weight and what do they
do
they take fiber start sugar protein and
other nutrients and convert them into
nutrients for both the bacteria and
nutrients for the cow
there's a second group you can see the
very small that produce the methane gas
there's also some protozoa
that they eat bacteria and ferment
starch and there's some fungi in there
that help break down fiber
so we're working with a large group
if we look at how many are in there this
is a chart that's based on beef cattle
40 gallons some of our cows may be 50.
but each mL of room and fluid has about
10 billion bacteria 10 million protozoa
at 1000 fungi what's a milliliter a
teaspoon is five milliliters so this is
one-fifth of a teaspoon
so there's a lot of microorganisms that
we're working with in this animal next
slide
and where are they located well the
rumen basically has three sections the
room and fluid part with the bugs in
there there's a room and fiber mat and
there's gaseous phase so the bugs are
down in the room and fluid portion of
the system
next slide
there's a symbiotic relationship between
the cows and the rumen
in stage one the cow provides housing
and nutrients for microbial growth
so the cow is sort of the landlord
provides an apartment for the
microorganisms to live in
stage two
is in the host animal utilizes some of
the room and microorganisms that go to
the intestine as a source of nutrients
so the cow provides a house but then the
cow also wants to rent back to pay for
that house next slide
so what does a cow provide we said
earlier low oxygen environment constant
temperature food for the bugs a neutral
environment and the cow removes the
garbage
next slide
what do the bugs provide they break down
fiber
they produce a high quality protein
they produce volatile fatty acids which
are energy for the cow and vfas are the
main energy source for dairy cows and
they're also building blocks for
synthesizing milk
Reuben bugs synthesized B vitamins and
they help in amino acid balancing
next slide
yeah there we go so this is a quick
overview of what happens the feed comes
in it has different fractions
non-protein nitrogen carbohydrates and
other forms of nitrogen
those are converted by the
microorganisms into microbial protein
microbial protein then goes to the
intestine as a source of metabolizable
protein
and that is really a source of amino
acids and the amino acids then are used
either to grow muscle and tissue or the
amino acids go down to support milk in
milk protein so that's a simple
schematic of the rumen system
next slide
Dr Mary Beth Hall University of Florida
put this together
and shows a similar thing when protein
enters the rumen it either goes to
ammonia
which is then converted with carp with
carbohydrates to microbial protein the
microbial protein then becomes absorbed
protein as a source of amino acids
next slide
Dr vargett Penn State put this together
in a carbohydrate side we have two sides
of the equation
we have the sugars and starches which
are highly ruinedly available
and they stimulate microbial growth and
digestion
and on the right side we have the fiber
which is more slowly available in
stimulates chewing rumination some of
that is digestible
and it's a lot and also the chewing
stimulates saliva production and some of
these cows May produce as much 70 80
gallons per day of saliva we have to
balance these two to keep the room and
bugs happy they need both the rapidly
available and the more slowly available
in the right proportions to maximize
their growth and development
next slide
so the generalized equation real quick
carbohydrates plus bugs plus nitrogen
plus the anaerobic environment equals
volatile fatty acids which are energy
for the cow in building blocks for milk
more bugs we get microbial protein and
that's the primary source of amino acids
in the intestine for the cow
there is some methane some carbon
monoxide and some other gases produced
in that room and during this
fermentation process
next slide
and what about methane
methane is a natural
product of
carbohydrate fermentation and
degradation
so the plant material enters the animal
bacteria for a minute during that
process there's some hydrogen and CO2
that are released
the methanogens which are a specific
type of bacteria then take hydrogen and
CO2 combine that to make methane
so if the animals functioning at all
there will always be some methane
produced we cannot eliminate methane our
goal is to try to to lower the amount of
methane produced next slide
this is another chart that looks at
methane production
the vfas we said are sorts of energy
we get the carbon dioxide the hydrogen
the methane and the other effect you
remember is if we produce methane that's
loss of energy the animal does not have
to make milk
so again methane is always going to be
there but we want to minimize the amount
so we maximize conversion of feed into
milk
next slide
one of the challenges we face is this
chart as cows eat more feed and the
rumen is more active there's more
methane produced in terms of grams or
liters per day
so are today's dairy cows produce a lot
more methane per cow than the cows did
20 years ago because they ate less feed
next slide
however when we look at the methane
production per unit of milk produced the
higher producing cows
since they're more efficient in
converting feed to milk produce less
methane per unit of milk produced
next slide
so what's the unique role of the
ruminant in this whole process
well cellulose is the most abundant
carbohydrate in nature and has a
specific linkage that humans and
monogastric and don't have the enzymes
to break down so you and I cannot
directly use cellulose however the
ruminants
have the microorganisms and the
microorganisms are able to produce a
cellulase enzyme to break that Bond so
the cellulose can become available as a
source of energy and nutrients for the
for the ruminant animal
and that way we can convert feeds that
you and I can't eat directly into high
quality products like meat and milk to
use in in our diets
and the point is if these feeds were not
used by the cap by ruminants most of
them would end up in landfills be
incinerated composted or disposed of in
some other method so the cows really the
original recycler of many of these
compounds next slide
so I talk about co-products for example
if you take wheat and you make flour you
get co-products like wheat meds wheat
bran and a couple other products high
fiber materials
the last one estimate is if we take 100
pounds of food
to process into say flour or something
about 37 pounds of that hundred are
co-products which can't be directly used
by you and I uh in our in our diets
and how much is out there well soybean
meal in the United States is about 51
million tons a year so we either feed
that or we we really don't have a good
use for it otherwise
the storage grains from ethanol
production around 38 million tons
and if not fed the animals as we said
they'd end up in landfills or other ways
because they have limited value in human
diets
next slide
next
next
this is an example of some of the
co-products that end up on the top left
you see Bakery and bagels and stuff
those are could be day old or can't be
used
there's chocolate that doesn't meet
specifications and there's a lot of
other feeds so the animals can use all
of these and convert them into meat milk
next slide
this is a list that Tom Overton put
together many years ago
showing that from all the different uh
processes we use to make food for people
whether it's oil extraction Brewing
Grain Milling
or other processes every one of these
has some type of a co-product that
potentially is a valuable feed for
animals and many of these directly or
not you could not be directly used by
the humans next slide
so the U.S EPA is is put together a food
recovery hierarchy that says what do we
do when we have these types of materials
and or food waste well the first one is
obviously find ways to reduce the amount
of waste to start with
secondly how much of this can we feed
the hungry people some of that's very
good for people and then if it's not
good for people the next stop best
option is feeding animals and you see
now at the bottom landfill is the last
option so anything we can do to to move
these Coke products and food waste
through animals really improves the
situation for everybody next slide
how much do we feed of co-products a
recent survey showed that the average in
the U.S is about 17.6 pounds per day
from co-products
for dairy cows
if we put that amount to all dairy cows
in New York that'd be 5400 tons per day
co-products that are New York dairy cows
are consuming
I surveyed a bunch of herds and found 25
percent of the ration the California
people 41 so basically 25 40 percent of
our Toleration are these co-products
that cows consume that are inedible by
people
next slide
and here's is an example ration this is
actual from a real farm
55 percent of that ration's forage
that's not going to be used by you and I
30 percent was co-products
so the only part of this total
derivation that could be used by humans
is that 12 which is corn grain
we humans can get some use out of corn
grain so 85 Plus percent of what this
cow is consuming
are materials that are not edible by you
and I
other surveys so that's 75 percent and
higher and there's herds in New York if
I grass-fed milk they're 100 of their
ration is not edible they're humans
next slide
so let's talk about human edible protein
production
it's just a simple
calculation that we can use to help look
at the importance of ruminants in
producing high quality food
there's two factors in this equation HCC
human error protein consumes how much
human edible protein do cows eat and the
second part is how much human edible
protein do cows produce and we want to
look at the ratio as their index
proficiency
we want that ratio to be greater than
one we get more human edible protein
produced than the cow consumes
that's our goal next slide
so let's look at an example from a
research study done in Sweden a number
of years ago
the controlled diet had cereal grains we
oats barley and soybean meal
and then they put together three
co-product diets that were fed and they
totally replaced the soil grains and
soybean meal so they used only
co-products like beet pulp distillers
grains he'd created rapeseed meal so the
copyright diets had no cereal grains no
soybean meal next slide
so what was the the ratio well the
controlled diet the cows were producing
less human edible protein than they were
consuming that's not good
but when we went to the co-product diets
you can see that they were making two
and a half times as much human edible
protein in the milk than they consumed
so the next next slide so that's good
the next step is then what's the quality
of the protein not only how much but how
good
and there's been protein quality scores
evaluated saying that the animal protein
quality is 1.4 and 1.8 times higher in
protein quality than plant proteins for
human edible for humans
so when we put both quantity and quality
together
the value of Animal product proteins is
about two and a 2.15 Times Higher
than human edible plant protein so that
the animal protein is a high quality
high value product for humans next slide
foreign so let's move to the
sustainability
what's the goal they have definitions
everybody has definitions this is one
used by the USDA in 1990 we want to
satisfy human food and fiber needs you
want to balance Environmental Quality in
the natural resource base
I want to make most efficient use of our
non-renewable resources and on-farm
resources
sustain the economic viability of farms
enhance quality of life for farmers and
Society that's sort of the goal next
slide
why is it important a recent survey
showed that greater 50 percent of
consumers buying dairy products are
interested in the availability of
sustainability information
if that number is only going to get
bigger because we move ahead
and there's also increasing pressure
from processors to adopt and document
sustainability practices to be able to
maintain access to markets and again
this will be more important in the
future
next slide
next
so has the industry made progress
this was the a study done years ago that
showed that between 1944 and 2007
what changes happen in carbon footprint
on the left panel you see the carbon
footprint per cow doubled during that
time
well that makes sense the 2000 the cows
in 2007 were making a lot more milk they
were bigger cows eating more feed so
they were obviously processing a lot
more material through the rumen
however when you look at the panel on
the right the carbon footprint per
kilogram of milk produced was decreased
by two-thirds
so they really did make a really big
change in efficiency uh when you look at
carbon footprint per unit of milk
produced reduced at about two-thirds
next slide
and then the follow-up study was looked
at 2007 to 2017.
milk yields per count went up about 4
500 pounds per cow
and if you look at every gallon of milk
produced in 2017 versus 2007 it is 17
less feed
21 less land 30 percent less water 20
percent less Fuel and a carbon footprint
went down 19 percent
so we decreased carbon footprint twice
once between 44 2007 and then 2007 to
2017. so the industry has made
significant progress there's still ways
to go we have made a lot of progress
next slide
I'm sorry
there's a national program that
recognizes dairy farms for their
sustainability efforts
and this is just the list of the ones in
the Northeast that have won this award
in the last few years you'll see these
are in Vermont Pennsylvania New York two
are New York herds are represented these
heard have been represented for
outstanding efforts to improve
sustainability of their operations next
slide
next next
what about changes in New York so Dr
Kristen Reed at Cornell and I in
cooperation with the Northeast
agribusiness feed Alliance said what
happens what's changed in New York
between 1999 to 2019.
so yes typical diets used our our
Cornell ration formulation model to see
what changes occurred next slide
number dairy cows went down about 11
milk per cow per year went up about 40
percent
totally New York milk production went up
about 26 percent
so we had some really improvements in
productivity
cows had to eat more feed that one up
but notice that we reduced duration
protein went down about 11 percent
phosphorus went down almost 19 percent
so we improved productivity but we
lowered the amount of nitrates in the
phosphorus consumed in the ration next
slide
so what does this really mean at the end
of the day if we calculate the change
the total amount of manure nitrogen tons
per year produced went down about eight
percent
told manure phosphorus tons per year
went down 20 percent
total ammonia emissions went down 17 and
our total New York methane emissions
comes pretty went down about three
percent so even though we have more
productive cows we have been able to
reduce environmental impact in New York
and that's an ongoing process that we
can do more of in the future
next slide
economics
none of this works unless Farms are
profitable
so we did a three-year study with eight
herds in the upper Susquehanna watershed
we lowered the diet protein decreased
manure excretion about 14 percent milk
production went up this slightly but the
big number here was income over purchase
feed cost went up by 137 dollars per cow
per year
so we made the counts more efficient in
converting feed to milk
decreased excretion of nutrients to the
environment and improved profitability
of the dairy farm that helps
sustainability next slide
a similar project is was done is done in
the New York City Watershed and again
when you look at the herds they target
the lower phosphorus
manure Fosters excretion went down 21
percent
under nitrogen down eight percent and
again increase in income over purchase
feed was up 157 dollars
so both of these studies and others
we've done show that generally when we
make cows more efficient reduce
excretion of the environment we also
improve profitability which is a key to
maintaining sustainability of a dairy
farm next slide
so then we did we said well let's do a
whole herd simulation
and we used a model from Dr Al rotz the
uh the pastor lab in Penn State
used a 1500 account New York Dairy herd
and this model integrates animals land
crops manure and economics evaluates all
of those integrates and as we change
things how do these shift
so we wanted to evaluate the impact of
best management practices to reduce the
environmental impact
of the farm next slide
model said that when we may Implement
our best management practices and we'll
talk about it with those in a minute
milk production went up
total and heart Farm nitrogen loss went
down 46 percent net return per cow went
up 27 so again milk was up returns were
up but we lowered the environmental
impact next slide
so if we look at what happened to the
carbon footprint in kilograms of car CO2
equivalents per kilogram of milk the
base situation was one which is very
similar to the previous estimates of the
carbon footprint and milk production of
U.S cows
when we implemented feed best management
practices alterations and forage quality
ratio forage to grain and the fat
feeding levels we reduce carbon
footprint about from one to about 0.8
and then when we put in the
the best management practices for field
crops and manure like adding cover crops
for example and going to an anaerobic
digester instead of an open Lagoon
carbon footprint went from one down to
about 0.6
so in this New York Farm simulation we
could have a significant impact on the
carbon footprint per unit of milk by
just employing some readily available
naturally available
uh best management practices
there's still ways to go maybe below the
0.6 next slide
next slide
so the key points
the dairy industry has made significant
process in improving the efficiency of
milk production while improving
profitability and decreasing emissions
to the environment
there's still opportunities and we're
continuing to move this trend in this
direction
Erie cows and other ruminants can
convert large quantities of human
irritable feeds into high quality
proteins producing human diets in 75 to
85 percent of the feed consumed by dairy
cows is not edible by humans it would
end up in landfills or compost or
incidentification
next slide
thank you
thank you so much Larry that was
fantastic
um overview of of what's going on and
how great it is to have cows in a cold
winter climate like ours where this
stored cellulose can be used in the
winter time
um uh Jen has just posted a a quick poll
uh just to give us feedback on this
webinar so if you could fill out that
poll that would be great
um we will now entertain questions
um just the first question there aren't
no we did not apply for arpus credits or
continuing education credits for those
um that ask that question
um so Larry Peter laner asks are corn
and soy soy cellulosic is it the case
that the grain heavy diet cows are
generally fed largely corn and soy
unlike grass do not require a rumen to
be digested
would you repeat that question I didn't
catch it okay
well there's several parts to it okay
first question is are corn and soy
cellulosic
they they have very small amounts not
much okay
is it the case that the green heavy diet
cows are generally fed largely corn and
soy unlike grass and therefore do not
require a rumen to be digested
that would that would be true in the in
the beef feedlot situation because there
they feed about uh 80 to 90 percent of
the ration is corn grain and soybean
meal in the dairy cow
uh if we look at the amount of corn
grain and soybean meal you saw on that
that one chart I had in that particular
uh
uh ration about 12 percent of the the
ration was corn so you know corn and
soybean are a small part of a toleration
foreign
we've got enough experience with
co-product feeds that we can replace the
corn and soy totally and still make a
lot of milk we've done trials at the
dairy Ford Center in Madison on that and
we we don't need corn and soy
why do we feed corn and soybean the
dairy cows they're a good source of
energy and protein they're available and
they've been relatively cheap but we
don't have to feed those we can feed
co-products and still make the milk so
it's just I think availability and
economics are the reason we fed corn and
soybean but there's still only a small
portion of the Toleration
okay thank you so Tom Hilton
asks do Pastor dairy cows produce less
methane than those fed a grain or food
byproduct diet
the amount of methane produced when you
feed forage only
will be a little bit higher than when
you feed some carbohydrate like starches
along with it
a lot of that will depend on the quality
of the forage
but usually the high forage diet is a
little higher in methane production
because you don't have these starches
and propionate from starch is an a sink
for methane in the rumen so that doesn't
mean High forage rations are bad at all
but you will make a little bit more
methane with the high foliage ration
without starches
and we'll hear more about that from
Andre in the next
okay Ron gamble uh so thank you so Ron
gamble then asks
um we hear about the cows have four
stomachs where does the rumen come into
this just what is chewing the cud is it
just going back to the same place
yeah the the when the feet when the feet
enters rooming the cow has to chew up to
some extent to get it to swallow it then
it goes in the room and forms a bolus
you might say
that bolus is
then regurgitated back up to the mouth
they chew again they're trying to reduce
particle size to get small enough that
it conventionally exit the rumen
and the cow's going to chew 40 or 50 000
times per day to to get these boluses uh
broken down small enough so the particle
can pass out of the rumen
so that's where the the chewing
rumination room and mat formation comes
in
that's a lot to ruminate oh yeah
that's been nine or eleven hours a day
chewing and ruminating they work hard
that's amazing
okay so Brett shedsoy asks why are the
dramatic difference between a beef
feedlot ration and a dairy ration in
terms of starch parentheses grain what's
the performance or output objective
difference between a dairy cow and a
beef animal
well the the feline animal you're trying
to get the maximum rate of gain and high
feed efficiency and you're only going to
feed them for about you know four five
six months
and then they're gone the dairy cow we
want them to be around for a long time
and so we we take advantage of the
Homegrown forages that we grow on our
Farms
and the co-products to make that race
and economical and so the dairy cow
really is a forage based situation
foreign
cow that way most of our cows are are
using the forages grown in the farm
we're in the beef feedlots they
accumulate animals from all over into an
area have to buy all the feed in and so
it's a lot easier to use uh grains
rather than a whole lot of forage in
plus they get better gain and efficiency
and profitability over the high green
diet
yeah okay if anybody else has questions
please add them into the question and
answer I have a question for you Larry
and it has to do with your last slide
um
um where you combine all of your best
management practices and you anticipate
that it's possible that we could get
down basically 40 percent of the
emissions from
current uh base emissions so that's
awesome because that helps us meet our
20 30 goal in New York state where we're
um
where we have a mandate to reduce
intermissions 40 by 2030. what is the
probability or possibility you think
that
um we could get this down to 85 by 2050
or what the dairy industry
um
uh
um
goals of a net zero Dairy
can you talk about what is the what it
what are your thoughts on how much
further we could go beyond
um what you all did in 2018 in the
development paper
well I think I think that's that's the
question the whole industry's looking at
now and as you know the DMI has the Net
Zero uh initiative by 2050. and they're
they're in a five they've got A
Five-Year Plan of research and they're
using some pilot Farms right now too to
see where we can go but there's there's
some new technologies coming along I
think that'll help us maybe get lower
than that 0.6 we ended up with how much
lower we can go I think it's going to
take us a few years to find that out
as Technologies come along and the other
challenge we have to think about is that
some of these Technologies fit on
certain type certain Farms
especially the ones with manure uh
systems where you have to put in
equipment they fit really on the larger
Farms they're maybe too expensive with a
smaller Farms so there may be a
difference in the type of farm as to
which Technologies we can use and adapt
but
and as we know more about rations for
cows we're going to do better there
there's some feed additives that look
very promising but none of them
are not yet available uh that have
potential to reduce methane so I think
there's some things in the Horizon we
can probably go lower in 0.6 how much
lower I guess we'll know that in five or
ten years
thank you okay so Brett has another
question I've heard that modern dairy
cow is kept for less than two lactations
due to having too much protein in their
diet presumably due to liver issues is
that true and how could you your
recommendation be used to improve that
statistic
yeah I think the average lactation
linked to somewhere like two and a half
or something like that but and it's not
from protein because really if we look
at the cows in the U.S cows in New York
we're feeding a lot less protein today
than we did even 10 years ago
so it's not protein it's just uh I think
the many herds uh as cows get older
they may or may not have some other
challenges or maybe they've got some new
younger cows coming in and they prefer
to milk a younger cow instead of the
older cow so I don't think we're losing
our lover cows are not going to get any
loss because of the high protein because
we're not feeding that much anymore I
think it's just a management practice
there's many herbs though if you go in
and look at them they've got cows out
there that are six eight ten years old
so there are cows out there that are
pretty old at times
okay
so
Peter
Peter was another question could you
please talk about the accuracy of
enteric methane emissions I've read some
recent studies suggesting the current
models are not that accurate
well
anytime you look at a uh a thing like
methane we had we had some challenges
number one measuring methane in
experiments there's always a standard
error standard deviation and that can be
uh very high at times depends on the
system and Andre May address that a
little bit
and then secondly as we develop models
to predict methane we have to build it
off the research data well there's
variability in the research data so
there's going to be some variability in
the model
so the way I tend to look at it is yes I
can run a model and say that instead of
450 grams per day we reduce it down to
420.
now it probably 450 is not exactly
correct the 420 is not exactly correct
but I think the directionality is
correct that we by making a change we
did we did reduce it
so all of these numbers always have
standard deviations beside them and
there's a lot of models out there they
all are a little bit different
but we just have to sort of I think take
the best information we have right now
use a model do our prediction and look
at directionality and no and never say
exactly this many grams and that many
grams but it's changed by about roughly
this percentage
so if anybody has any more questions
please put them in the Q a so I'm going
to follow up on that Larry do you do you
have information I think Cornell has
these stalls that they're supposed to be
installing and Mike Van Amberg might be
doing some studies to get more accurate
measurements of enteric methane is that
do you know much about that can you talk
about that a little bit
well Joe uh yeah Joe Joe McFadden Mike
and Amberg have gotten some funding to
build uh some stalls on campus
basically uh you put a cow inside of a
chamber where you can measure total
inflow and outflow of air and gases
so they'll be able to get some uh some
more some direct measurements uh I think
that's probably not going to I think
they're just getting ready to start
building the Stalls so it'll probably be
a year or two before you see many
results
uh most of the original methane work in
the United States was done in that type
of an environment at USDA Beltsville
Maryland had an excellent system like
that unfortunately at some point in time
the government decided it was too
expensive and shut that system down
so now we're getting back to building
that type system but and then there's
some indirect methods andre'll talk
about the method he he's used which
doesn't need a stall but it does still
give a way to measure methane emissions
by cows so we'll be getting some more
data and again even in the chamber
there's always variability day-to-day in
cow to cow
okay so I have another question
um so this idea can you talk a little
bit about the the basics of what a feed
amendment is and how that um uh impacts
the methane emissions and then if you
might share some of your favorite feed
amendments Beyond feed efficiency like
you've been talking about how to improve
the milk production efficiency just
using the natural biology of the cow and
so could you just talk a little bit more
about what you think is
um what you think are some promising
feed amendments that can help change the
conditions inside of the cow so that the
total methane is reduced
there's there are a number of
feed attitudes you might say they're
being looked at in research
um
and they they seem to be able to reduce
methane anywhere from five to say 30
percent
uh the challenge with most of them is
right now the day is very early
a lot of it's lab data there's only one
or two that have actually gone to a Cow
trial in a long-term Cow trial
and
in at least one and they once they get
data then they may depending how they
decide to Market it they may have to go
through FDA to get approval so it could
be a slow process so right now the best
way to reduce methane is to get a high
quality well-balanced ration keep the
animal healthy and that's the best we
can do and we can lower methane
significantly by doing that like you saw
on that slide we went from uh carbon
footprint one to carbon footprint of 0.8
employing what we have available right
now
so we probably can again go down from
point eight maybe a little bit lower
than that
but I think that's where we are
five years from now maybe there'll be a
number of adages out there but right now
there's none really uh
commercially uh working at this point
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu